yeah that roll sweet sweet roll you're
still recording aren't you
[Laughter]
[Music]
so Auslander we got to see Diablo 3 on
the switch finally I always thought that
that tweet was immaculate I told them it
was immaculately and then they're like
oh it was just coincidental well now
it's a real thing it is a real thing and
I guess we've just been sort of waiting
for that shoe to drop because we always
knew it was gonna happen because it made
the most sense to bring it to the switch
and actually going hands-on with it like
it just totally played great like a rant
at 60fps it uh you know we have we have
all the content that was packed in with
the current version of Diablo 3 and I
thought it's pretty great yeah it was
awesome to get hands on like you said
60fps both handheld and docked handheld
felt good like it's it's cool to think
that I can actually play Diablo 3 on a
flight and you know potentially with
friends potentially with randoms if they
happen to also have Diablo 3 they're on
the flight because you don't need Wi-Fi
or Internet just got that Bluetooth
connectivity likely yeah land play Allah
like Mario Kart you know like you just
sync up you can also play on like one
joi con which is like insane to think of
they're telling us about you know just
how much of a like revelation or like
how cool it was for them to finally get
that to work and work properly I think
that's a little bit cumbersome I've
never really wanted to play a game on
that small a d-pad I guess but you know
it works that's all that matters right
and yeah like this could be the third
time I buy Diablo just because you know
like you said it makes a lot of sense
for that portability right and it's cool
to kind of like relive that experience
again and I know there's a you know
yourself and like I wouldn't be shocked
if we got right back into it
and uh one thing I really liked just
again going back to sort of the
portability but also just how easy was
it to get into even though I have like
hours of experience with the PC version
I had very little experience with the
console version and I sort of you know
there was an initial like you know sort
of clumsiness trying to get used to the
new controls but um you know I did
appreciate sort of the just how
responsive it felt like the the added
like a dodj feature which I actually it
was a big help because for some reason
the demo we played was like sort of high
level play like you know we were playing
I was like I challenge riff 45 at there
yeah about torn which is like the
perfect way to get like newcomers into
Diablo 3 they just have just throw them
into the fire so to speak but it was a
yeah I mean just how we played it was a
we basically just sat down on a couch
and we literally did couch co-op play
like you know it was me you and one of
the developers and we just sort of
dropped in yeah we're gonna be dropping
yeah it was it was like you said it was
definitely a challenge at first is
getting the muscle memory back but like
once you kind of figured it out and once
you understood like the builds that they
had set up it was like oh this makes a
lot of sense and as you said a lot of
that functionality is still there so
like the dodge roll is just constable
only right so good to have that also has
that functionality were you know if some
people are kind of farther ahead than
someone that's back behind it'll
actually like teleport you to the rest
of the group which is good
and all the seasons as you mentioned all
that stuff is coming with this version
so you know when the next season drops
for PC and also for you know Xbox and
Playstation the switch will also get
that which is really cool and there's
still one thing that I think is awesome
that console has that PC Diablo doesn't
have which is the ability to send
through the mail
just like legendaries or different items
that you might not be using but maybe I
know Mike plays a certain class or
something I'm like hey here's this
two-handed axe for your barbarian or
something because I'm never gonna use it
whereas right now in PC D although you
can only do that if you're playing with
them in that game but now I have the
luxury of sending in like extra stuff or
anything like that to my friends and
things like that which is awesome
and yeah just a just a fun experience I
think both handheld and playing with
like a pro controller for me it felt
better playing on a pro controller but
very good on on handheld mode yeah it's
such a great way to get into Diablo 3 2
is not only are you getting the most
complete version of Diablo 3 that
includes like all the classes the
available classes including like the
necromancer seasons you know the recent
expansion Reaper of souls you know
you're getting just the sort of the the
comfort of like the switches portability
which is you know a new thing for Diablo
cos is the first time the game is
actually portable you can bring it with
you like anywhere on a plane or just you
know plug it to a friend's house or
whatever
I think the added benefit or coolness I
guess if you're a big Nintendo fan is
you know seeing some of those exclusives
that we talked about earlier you know
seeing Ganon as a armor transmog and you
know having those pets and I think
there's also like a Triforce banner icon
or yeah this is for your character
player icons a portrait so yeah kind of
also the Ikuko pet because everyone goes
there koukos and you can have one follow
you around
yeah I mean I'm looking forward to it I
like you you know have poured many hours
into the game and I probably am getting
a third version of Diablo you know I
think it's like you said it just makes a
lot of sense for a lot of reasons and
it's cool to finally see it actually hit
on switch now I'm looking forward to you
know all these other Diablo
announcements that we're hopefully
getting by the end of the year maybe
come Blizzcon since they've have you
know multiple projects but cool that's
like the announcement of the switch and
then being on this which is like one of
those first like layers of peeling back
on that onion
[Music]
you want to see me turn into a demon